grundsätzlich thema frauen thema fdp fdp
das ist ein großes thema und ich als
wählerin frage mich natürlich auch wenn
ich mich informieren und gucke ich als
frau was tun sie etwas tut die fdp für
mich als frau warum sollte ich wie fdp
wählen
bei ganz vielen fragen gibt es doch in
bad gar keine unterscheidung zwischen
männern und frauen sie haben ein
interesse oder ihr ein interesse daran
dass es freuen wenn die frauen also was
denken sie dass die frauen wussten dann
müssen also nee ich beantworte jetzt
nicht für sie was sie als frau wollen
weil dass wir jetzt wieder der typisch
alt männliche art die türe der mann
erklärt der frau was sie zu wollen
stimmt nicht das stimmt
ich denke mir dass sie machen sich ja
gedanken mit ihrem team wie kriegen sie
mehr frauen als männer reden oder auch
als parteimitglieder der nummer dass da
war ich natürlich was wovon gehen sie
aus was sie erlebt hatte das fdp ok
versteht jetzt jetzt verstehe ich die
frage fragen also es kommt noch ich
glaube zunächst mal es gibt nicht die
frauen so wie es auch nicht die männer
gibt es gibt frauen die wollen dieses
gehen und so weitere wir wenden unsere
ich wende mich an die frauen die zuerst
sagen die wichtigste gesellschaftliche
aufgabe in unserem land ist dass das
bildungssystem funktioniert und zwar von
der kita bis hin zur beruflichen bildung
bis zur hochschule da haben wir viel zu
tun sagt nur lernen auf distanzieren in
corona pandemie wie läuft das eigentlich
mit den kitas gibt es in der kita
eigentlich zum beispiel für die kleinen
mädchen genug förderung in diesem
bereich der so auf
naturwissenschaftliches interesse
vorbereitet eine ganz wichtige frage um
später auch dann junge frauen für berufe
zu interessieren den man gut verdient
dann glaube ich dass frauen wie männer
ein interesse daran haben dass es einen
sicheren arbeits und ausbildungsplatz
gibt ja das ist unterscheidet männer und
frauen nicht männer und frauen
unterscheiden sich vielleicht darin
welche welche argumente sie überzeugen
oder oder welche biker stil gut gefunden
wird ich glaube frauen sind viel
sachlicher als männer männer begeistern
sich gerne auch an so polemischen
formulierungen während frauen immer
sagen die zweck mit der polemik war
ist glaube ich das so gut ist dass davis
ihn brechen ein grund dafür dass so
wenig frauen in der politik sind also
ich zum beispiel finde dass es die
politik kommt mir manchmal so vor es
wird der der am lautesten poltert wird
gehört das ist so wenn wir in
stereotypen reden ich bin ganz bei ihnen
es gibt nicht die männer und die frauen
aber ich glaube es ist ein stelle
typisch männerbild dass man laut sprich
gerade die politiker dass man polter
dass man quasi für sich so und im
frauen- und es beobachte ich auch
einfach im berufsleben in konferenzen
wenn ihr nichts zu sagen haben dann
sagen sie nichts wenn männer schon dazu
tendieren einfach nochmal damit einmal
der punkt gesetzt ist bei der konferenz
einfach noch mal was zu sagen egal ob es
jetzt der erfordere auch schon gesagt
hat oder ob es keine neue idee ist
glauben sie dass das zu ein grund dafür
ist und man spricht ja auch immer von
der fdp dass sie ein frauenproblem habe
also gerade bei wählerinnen aber auch in
den internen rein
woran liegt das nicht sie waren der
lieferprobleme schnell beantwortet gerne
beide fragen nur sie haben einmal die
politik und einmal die fdp gesorgt das
macht es mir schwer die frage ist noch
nicht beantwortet also also dann sage
ich nur ganz kurz noch ein paar andere
themen die speziell bei frauen die
besondere rolle spielen dass gender pay
gap beispielsweise ein großes
gerechtigkeitsproblem nach
gleichberechtigung gleichberechtigungs
fragen
ich glaube dass bestimmte
gesellschaftspolitische fragen für
frauen sehr interessant sind und wo wir
viel zu tun haben zum beispiel die
nichtkommerzielle leihmutterschaft und
andere dinge mehr so aber jetzt zu der
der frage politik bin ich übrigens dafür
dass wir das in deutschland
liberalisieren
man hat jetzt wären corona gesehen wie
viele babys zum beispiel in ungarn von
deutschen familien deutschen eltern
nicht nach deutschland kommen konnten
hier ist die leihmutterschaft verboten
dann werden die familien mit
kinderwunsch denen sie nicht erfüllen
können ins ausland geschickt also warum
machen wir uns da nicht aber okay jetzt
zu dem thema frauen und politik
ich habe da keine ganz abschließende
antwort aber mein gefühl ist frauen sind
sachlicher weniger an selbstdarstellung
interessiert
frauen haben meistens noch sehr viele
andere themen neben beruf und politik
weil lieben lage pflege der eltern
kinder 2020 hin oder her in den aller
meisten paare und familien kontexten
leisten frauen da
den hauptteil der arbeit in der wert
aller ihnen würden sie im jahr in
elternzeit gehen sollten sie mal vater
hin wenn sie dann sagen jetzt mag ich
mache das hier ein jahr babypause
gerade weil wir das ansprechend immer
wieder sind es ja die frauen es brechen
er einfach nicht aus deutschland sondern
und serbien ich habe da selbst ich habe
damit überhaupt kein problem bei mir
stellt sich jetzt gegenwärtig die frage
nicht und konkrete fragen sollte man
dann beantworten wenn sie sich denn sie
sich stellen aber ich habe damit kein
problem
bezog etwa zum beispiel auf leitende
mitarbeiter von mir wenn die sagen ein
jahr elternzeit auf männer
das ist kein kein problem allerdings in
der gesellschaft insgesamt fürchten sich
männer noch so stark sind mir noch
nichts männer sind auch teilweise
schwach dass sie sich nicht lösen können
von von den klischees und den
vorurteilen dies dann im kollegenkreis
gibt auch du willst ein jahr raus weil
sie keine karriere machen und ein
starker mann würde dann sagen ja ich
gehe jetzt raus aber wieder hat trotzdem
karriere aber nicht jedermann ist so
stark deshalb willkommen in unserer welt
ja ich arbeite genannt deshalb sollte
man auch nicht immer so sagen die männer
die wollen das gar nicht ob das viele
männer da auch so eine stützung brauchen
nach dem motto du bist auch weiterhin
ein in anführungsstrichen echtermann
auch wenn du dich um die um die kinder
kümmert schnitzer und du hattest ja
gerade angesprochen ich finde ganz
wichtig in dem zusammenhang wenn frauen
sich so verhalten wenn sie leide sind
wenn sie sich nicht trauen wenn sie sich
auch teilweise ja sexismus anhören
müssen dass halt immer was mit dem
verhältnis zu tun gewürzen wir wo ich
schon wieder zur strukturellen
benachteiligung kommen wenn das so zum
beispiel zehn männer und eine frau sind
dann ist die garantie für diese angriffe
und auch für die einschüchterung die gar
nicht entstehen viel größer als wenn das
pari pari wäre und bezogen auf die fdp
zum beispiel 21 prozent frauenanteil
immer noch zu wenig cdu es auch nicht
besser
aber ich meine hier gerne bereit habe
aber wie schafft man diese dieses klima
das sozusagen das ziel muss ja wirklich
auch sein dass man da eine
gleichberechtigung hinbekommt auch wenn
das thema quote schwierig gesehen wird
bei der fdp sage ich mal gerade unter
dem liberalen verständnis und ansatz
auch sozusagen der gleichberechtigung
der gleichwertigkeit wäre es doch
wünschenswert dass man frauen dafür
begeistert und wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel an die liebe katja sogar denke
die ich sehr schätze persönlich wo es ja
vor vielen jahren so ein wahlkampf gab
der beste mann für hamburg da musste ich
ehrlich gesagt an meinen vater denken
der immer zu mir gesagt hat du bist wie
ein sohn für mich
ich würde kein kompliment ich finde man
kann auch als frau zeigen wer man ist
und er braucht kein wahlplakat
beispielsweise der beste mann in hamburg
ich weiß also drei jahre her
das ist nicht ein paar jahre das
müsstest du dann mit katja suding selber
klären weil das war ja ihr wahlplakat da
sie sich ausgesucht hat aber ich habe ja
noch die studie die jetzt zum beispiel
ist ja kein kein mann der das ihr
gegeben sie wollte ja krisen gag machen
ja aber eure studie da kam er einst zu
tage was ich sehr spannend fand dass
teilweise die männer mehr sozusagen
quote und förderung für die frauen
befürwortet haben als die frauen selber
ja das ist und die frage was ist das für
eine kultur
frauen denken dass es vielleicht besser
wäre also frage ich wie gesagt noch mal
es gibt nicht wie frauen sondern es gibt
frauen und die sind sehr individuell und
die frauen in der fdp sind eben ganz
weit mehrheitlich gegen eine quote ganz
weit mehrheitlich aber unter den frauen
in der bevölkerung insgesamt düsen sind
auch nicht 100 prozent für eine quote
ist eine mehrheit der frauen ist für
eine quote ich hab jetzt keine aktuelle
zahl anderen voraussetzungen ja aber
jemand so ist schlank und ebenso dass
die frauen in der fdp entschiedene
gegnerin der quote sind
ich selbst würde mich von einer quote
vielleicht überzeugen lassen
aber unsere frauen haben die debatte
wollen wir gar nicht mehr führen dass
also erledigt bei uns und die frage
warum haben wir wenig frauen hängt
vielleicht auch mit klischees zusammen
die fdp ist eine partei nur für die
wirtschaft nur für
ältere männer das stimmt gar nicht ich
glaubte man so die themen insgesamt
nimmt eine frau die interesse hat im
beruf voranzukommen
die will dass ihre kinder eine gute
schule haben in der auch zum beispiel
das thema leistung eine rolle spielt und
vorbereitung auf das wirtschaftsleben so
die findet bei uns das beste angebot §
209 10 a also die information über einen
legalen schwangerschaftsabbruch bei
einem arzt riesenproblem
wie sind eure studier aufhebung der
weigert sich das ins gesetz aufzunehmen
dann die frage eben angesprochen
nichtkommerzielle leihmutterschaft cdu
weigert sich das gesetzlich vernünftig
zu regeln und auch eine ganze reihe
anderer fragen wie zum beispiel hier die
frage
weibliche vorstandsmitglieder die
während des mutterschutzes aus ihren
jobs abberufen werden dann mußt enormer
druck auf die cdu ausgeübt werden damit
sie das korrigiert also ich wundere mich
immer dass wir angesprochen werden die
fdp habe ein frauen ich habe ja alle
parteien andere aber andere parteien
machen
aber die gesundheit gegen die
integrieren beispielsweise an 41 sind
schon unterschied zu 17
klar aber die bei den grünen ist es so
dass mehr frauen als männer
die grünen wären die haben auch nicht
ausgeglichenes geschlechterverhältnis
bei den grünen wählen tatsächlich mehr
frauen als männer bei uns mehr männer
als frauen aber es wäre doch zum
beispiel erstrebenswert sind 50
irgendwie mal anzupeilen und bin ganz
bei dir ist natürlich auch ein randthema
also wie viel weibliche vorstände haben
wie ich hab mir die dax sei heute eine
stadt ist wieder gesunken
mit der hinter kugel gleich natürlich
willkommen sie glaube ich eine nicht so
viele breite weibliche wähler mit dem
thema glaube dass das ein also zunächst
mal sind es ja viele frauen die sich
dafür engagieren
auf welche die hier schon zu gast
gewesen sind da müssten sie diesen ja
auch sagen das ist nur ein randthema
sagen genau verena poster gehört zu den
aber ich sage ihnen warum das kein
randthema ist es ist ein symbolthema das
überhaupt irgendeine frau aus
irgendeinem job vorstellen oder sonstwas
abgerufen werden kann weil sie ein kind
hat das ist nicht an ran
das ist ein symbolthema das ist nah bei
den menschen
ich habe da schon ist also meine erstes
thema war eben die kita und die schulter
und die schule war mein erstes thema
aber ich glaube wir dürfen auch über
solche symbole themen sprechen weil sich
daran auch auch etwas fest macht und wie
gesagt warum bin ich hier weil ich ja
dafür werben will dass mehr weibliche
mitglieder auch zur fdp kommen wenn ich
dafür sind in der studie aber die düsen
gerade angesprochen hat und ich finds ja
also das muss ich sagen er gut dass die
fdp mal sowas macht und überprüft aber
da waren
es findet wahnsinnig viel soeben
hinterstübchen also einfacher so seidel
am seil haben landrat karl heim kommt
was ist das allein parteien so habe
jetzt haben wir christian lindner und es
möchte ist mit ihm ist was macht man
dagegen weil genau das ist auch mein
eindruck von politik das eben sehr viel
in seilschaften geklärt wird und dass
frauen dort wieder eine chance gegeben
wird noch dass ich und das muss ich als
frau sagen noch dass ich lust hätte ich
hätte keine lust wenn ich mich für meine
ideale einsetzen möchte dann und mir
dann erstmal sie haben sie haben recht
ist allerdings ein problem das nicht nur
auf die fdp oder die politik gezogen ist
sondern ich erlaube mir die offene frage
ansehen fällt frauen eigentlich
insgesamt das bilden von netzwerken sich
gegenseitig zu fördern leicht oder
schwer
ich lese so oft über dieses schlagwort
viel temperament und dann stellt man
doch fest dass diejenigen die sich da
ändern wollen
doch ganz oft auch miteinander in ich
sage mal intrigen verstrickt sind also
dein bus und echte wirkliche frauen
jetzt dann ist das irgendwie ich
übrigens das stimmt ich würde ihn sogar
recht geben aber es gibt einen grund
dafür
und das liegt daran dass den frauen
immer eingeredet wird entweder du oder
ich und da sind wir wieder bei der
strukturellen benachteiligung denn wenn
es da eine gleichwertigkeit eine
gleichberechtigung geben würde würde
diese stutenbissigkeit auch nicht
entstehen und ich finde auch mitnichten
dass es so ist dass frauen die besseren
menschen sind also da habe ich ganz
andere
lebenswirklichkeiten auch erlebt
insbesondere auch als menschen
aber ich sage auch in der politik also
ich sag mal gerade in der spitzenpolitik
also da musst du einfach auch gewisse
qualitäten haben und das hat auch mit
durchsetzungsvermögen zu tun aber ich
glaube schon dass es auch strukturelle
gründe hat führungskräfte müssen
weibliche kräfte dann auch fördern und
ich hab das machen wir zum beispiel bei
uns ich habe eine parlamentarische
geschäftsführerin siebeneinhalb jahre
hatte ich zwei generalsekretären die
haben zwei ausschussvorsitzenden im
deutschen bundestag wir haben ohne quote
44 prozent frauenanteil in
führungsgremien und ich glaube darüber
kann man was tun
das ist dann zwar nur da oben die sie
dann sagen würden aber es ist zumindest
symbolhaft wichtig
[Musik]